foreign
videos on them or which you should check
out how does that relate to today's list
then well our list today is about main
characters being underestimated and
making that arrogant opponent pay for it
you see where I'm going with this one
don't you yep there's nothing more
satisfying and stimulating than someone
underestimating your main character only
for said main character to prove
everyone wrong in a big big way so sit
tight we're gonna be in for a ride today
let me start things off with World
trigger
I think that oh Bullies Are a bane of
every student's existence anime has them
in bunches too and you know the thing
with bullies right they think they're
hot stuff and look down on people just
because they've got numbers
unfortunately these bullies from World
trigger underestimated the wrong guy you
might isn't someone you should take
lightly and these idiots learned that
the hard way Osama gets the full brunt
of their wrath and it looks as if Yuma
doesn't want to get involved however
when the leader of the Buddies turns his
attention to Yuma it doesn't take more
than a few seconds for everyone to
realize he's made a really big mistake
and the guy paid for it with his leg
Yeah that's gotta hurt not much has
heard of these guys after this incident
pretty much a confirmation of their
status and what they really amounted to
right deservingly so I think too
nobody
bullies aren't the only trollsome people
in school there's also the Arrogant
senior one of which is hathori
honestly mahoka has one of the most
fulfilling themes for teens which is why
I think it became quite a hit it's all
about striking back all the stereotypes
from labels and the statuses assigned to
you you take those assumptions and you
stick a bullet-shaped hole right through
them in some ways turning tatsuya into
practically God may have been Overkill
to push the themes and premise of the
series I'd be lying if I said that
seeing him prove others wrong was
unsatisfying when Hattori underestimates
him for being a weed all it takes is a
jewel for datsuya to shock the world in
a battle between I suppose a terrible
magician and one of the veterans in the
school it's easy to write off the weed
but not if said weed is none other than
godsuya and he makes short work of his
opposition a preview to come for the
even more insane Feast that will leave
everyone in awe later
[Music]
how about this moment from black
Summoner Nick
[Music]
a staple of power fantasy series like
mahoga is this element of proving
everyone wrong when people look down on
you you strike back and shove their
words back at them with full force black
Summoner has one of these moments when
Kelvin finds himself face to face with a
group of murderers for murderers with
such reputation and Loud mouths all it
takes is one slime to beat all of them
yeah a slime solos all of them making
all of their talking and underestimating
of Kelvin all the more hilarious in
hindsight yep I know that nobody's in a
fantasy anime and this result is nothing
surprising for viewers still it's quite
the treat seeing them get bodied like
that too weak Kelvin says talk about
turning the trash talk right back at
your opponents for this one is it feels
again
vs deep sea king is the next moment on
the list
now you'd think with saitama's Feats
villains would have learned their
lessons by now apparently Deep Sea King
didn't get the memo and his victories
over numerous Heroes got into his head a
little bit well after holding his own
against Sonic and beating genos I don't
exactly blame him do I but after the way
he toyed with Moomin Rider I don't ever
think anyone will have sympathy for him
when he gets one shot in my saithama
it's a glorious moment to see his hits
finally get no soul by a hero for the
numerous Feats that he's been shown to
be able to do he really did find a match
inside armor who took some trash right
back talk about getting a taste of your
own medicine the difference here is
however is that saitama easily backs up
his claim and punches a hole right
through the villain even stopping the
rain in the process Deep Sea King takes
one of saithama's signature punches and
he's done for
foreign
from magical powers to Superheroes how
about we scale it down a little bit with
this Niche anime hinomaru sumo
I'm not sure how many people watch this
anime about Sumo But Here I Am featuring
it and hopefully getting a new anime
added to your watch list hinomaru Sumo
is a pretty good watch all things
considered even if you're not into the
sport it's also got the Sports Anime
staple the opening act where some bully
or delinquent who's just a full of
himself battles the young upstart said
delinquent humor thinks he's some big
boss as he destroys the shinya Sumo rig
and when hiromaru lays down the gauntlet
the gang just can't help her laugh at
him hinomaru is not the most imposing
figure around but when the time comes to
take it to the ring he easily turns
things around even with the unfair rules
he completely destroys his opponent
before being revealed to be a former
Champion that's why we don't judge my
appearance folks hinomaru sumo's a fun
show that got me through a lot of
emotions it's a pretty complete
experience and while it's understandable
why it isn't more popular you should
probably give it a shot sometime soon
foreign
if you like what you've seen so far
don't hesitate to hit that like button
arnos versus Sasha is up next on the
list
how can we feature and not mention what
I call his 2020s equivalent arnos anyway
Misfit of Demon King Academy and mahoka
have some similarities thematically sure
it's just an element or two but it's
also got the score setting with a
god-like protagonist who gets
underestimated a lot early on letting it
after seeing arnos correct his teacher
and even show off how much better he is
you think that Sasha would stay in her
Lane not this time though and she thinks
that she's got it all under control when
arnos appears solo and approaches her
so-called Invincible Castle it appears
that her confidence is warranted only
for arnos to just do the unthinkable and
toss that puny Castle aside in such a
comedic manner the magic Jewel
afterwards is nothing but a formality at
this point arnos even defeats her with a
low level spell truly showing the
difference between the two of them I
don't think you can make an even bigger
statement than that
foreign
villains we've all seen this coming
haven't we bat devil in particular is
quite the unpleasant individual when he
lays his eyes on Genji he sees not a
formidable opponent not even a Sumptuous
meal for a devil like him when he
realizes too late that denji is a devil
like he is an arm is already gone and
bat devil finds himself in the fight of
his life likewise Genji finds himself in
a situation where he may have bitten off
more than he can chew when bat devil
proves to be every bit as powerful as
one could imagine thankfully with the
power of good old action hero
determination and denji's insatiable uh
lusting are heroes able to make his big
comeback and save the day overall a
rather short but pretty cool fight scene
with some rocking background music too
oh and one of the more brutal deaths in
anime on the other hand it's nothing
much for chainsaw man standards
[Music]
foreign
next we have Luffy versus Bellamy
[Music]
remember Bellamy who oh that hyperactive
guy who spends his notable screen time
taunting Luffy pissing him off and
generally being an obnoxious guy about
it he knows how to talk big though just
that when he comes to putting his money
where his mouth is it's just pure
disappointment this is a Luffy who's
grown since their last encounter mind
you but as they say arrogance turns
people blind and Bellamy was just too
caught up in himself to be aware of this
as he ricochets all over the place we
all know Luffy's just letting him have
his fun and when the time's right Luffy
just smacks him down defeating him and
his powered up attacking one punch my
hero made he looks so easy and with this
Bellamy's time in the series as anything
near a threat comes to an end
foreign
[Music]
it's easy to look down on a guy as
obnoxious as early astha and this is a
guy who wants to take the entrance exam
while having magical powers of a wet
noodle yeah somewhat like seki could
definitely see him as a stepping stone
however when the test shifts to the
combat section it's all over for seki
Imagine giving your opponent the first
move just because you're so full of
yourself that's a life-ending mistake in
actual combat and while we've seen big
villains do that with much success Zeke
is nowhere near their league faster just
blitzes the guy and finishes it all in
one shot Black Clover is a really nice
Underdog Story and scenes like this
early on set the tone quite well I think
it's a pretty inspirational theme for
young anime fans too to not let others
assumptions Define Who You Are
finishing off the list is Ichigo versus
biakuya
[Music]
amongst our society's captains yakuya is
the one whose pride is second to none
maybe Eisen can give him a run for his
money but eisen's not the time to
underestimate his opponents badly until
that last encounter with Ichigo in
biakuya's case the repeated victories
against Ichigo solidified his
assumptions about this kid he never took
him seriously even when Ichigo did the
unthinkable and mastered Bankai in such
a quick time biakuya was quick to brush
it off until Ichigo easily deflected
sembon zakura's attack and the prideful
Captain was finally forced to
acknowledge the monster he created it
was his role as a war in ichigo's
proverbial wall that helped the upstart
push Beyond his limits and accelerate
his training the battle did continue
further and Ichigo did find himself on
the ropes with another entity saving him
but the first part of the battle where
our hero showed off his Bankai and the
getsuga tensho was a thing of beauty a
Redemption for all the underestimating
done to him
[Music]
as Alice comes to a close I want to know
what your favorite moment is heck you
can tell me about other moments that you
might think I've missed too on the other
hand if you're looking for more videos I
do recommend the satisfying Moments
video head over to my channel and browse
for something you might enjoy once again
thanks for watching the video wishing
you a good day and I hope to see you
again